hey gq i'm dr eric bender i'm a
psychiatrist and psychotherapist and
today i'll be looking at some patients
from earth 616. this is the mental
breakdown
[Music]
thor so you guys want to drink food what
are we drinking beer tequila all sorts
of things
buddy
you all right yes fine why why is this
donut look all right you look like
melted ice cream
so what's up just over a hangover if
this guy walked into my office i think
oh he seems pretty jovial pretty
friendly guy i would ask him how he's
doing and
have him just tell me about himself what
i'd find interesting is how he was
functioning in the past to now one of
the questions i often ask people when
they come into my office is what brings
you in now as opposed to say you know
two months ago last year something's
going on for him and as i talked to him
more i'd learn that
thor's grieving here he just went
through an incredible ordeal where he
had a chance to use his hammer and to
hit thanos and to kill him
it didn't work
it didn't work at all so
thor is dealing with that loss
loki has just died
asgard was destroyed almost all the
asgardians are extinct at this point
that is an incredible amount of loss
that he's dealing with so i would say
he's likely grieving the difference
between grief and a depression would be
that in grief there is
an expected depression almost there's an
expected devastation a sadness that
outside of that grief outside of that
loss
would actually be considered something
that needs a lot of attention and would
be diagnosable
but after someone dies people naturally
will have a sadness that's crushing
sometimes with depression there isn't a
particular event that's
spurring on these
symptoms you might be really down and
not have any joy from anything in your
life
and there's no reason or at least people
could say i i don't understand this but
grief again has that initial
onset in talking with thor i would find
out that
that's more what's going on he's really
grieving all these things when this
image of thor hit the internet he was
dubbed fat thor that's really actually
damaging not only to thor's ego but to
people who do struggle with weight
having a character like this walk on
screen and hear audiences just laugh or
see him be the butt of jokes that's
really
uncomfortable and really awful people
gain weight sometimes when they're
depressed people gain weight when
they're not depressed doesn't mean that
they're useless or the blood of jokes or
should be laughed at people are people
and i imagine that actually
he would be dealing with people reacting
to his weight and that's something that
can be really hard for people to
struggle with his friends these avengers
are a source of support for him they
come to him they want him to know that
they care about him and they also want
to recruit him back and say we still
find you useful we still find you
somebody we want to be with i don't like
that there's comments about what he's
been doing in his body and his body
weight they're supportive otherwise
though while thor is grieving the loss
of all these people who've died at the
hands of thanos because he couldn't stop
thanos also it's important to note this
is the first time thor's ever lost he's
never lost a battle before and it's a
huge part of his identity that he's
somebody who can always win so the fact
that he's lost that piece of him that's
a big deal a lot of times i'll see
people that have
a change in something in their life that
makes them feel like part of their
identity is gone and that's a big thing
to have to cope with
deadpool
when it comes time to licking wounds
there's no place like home
ah and i share that home with someone
you've met the old blind lady from the
laundromat al
god i miss cocaine
her
fourth wall break inside a fourth wall
break that's like
16 walls
deadpool is a character who uses humor
to cope with everything in our lives
when we are at risk for having our
emotions really challenged or when we
can be hurt we use things called coping
mechanisms or sometimes even called
defense mechanisms if we think
something's really going to hurt us and
we're not consciously aware of these
things these are things that just we've
embodied over time and figured out how
to do there's primitive coping
mechanisms or defense mechanisms meaning
they're not very nuanced one would be
projections saying you're so angry but
actually you're the one who's angry and
then there are more mature coping
mechanisms and that includes humor and
deadpool does that throughout every
movie every comic book story that he's
in here he's breaking the fourth wall
he's using that in a way to connect with
the audience i think connection in the
deadpool story is very interesting
because this is a guy who is pretty much
indestructible he is going to watch
people in his life die one by one
whether it's a loved one whether it's a
friend whatever it is the superheroes
will stay alive most likely not all of
them and deadpool doesn't necessarily
hang out with him all the time as we
know he's someone who's coping with that
reality and he's probably pushing that
away and not even dealing with it not
even wanting to think about it we do see
how much of a spiral he gets into when
his girlfriend is killed in the movie
again he's trying to cope with that he's
not going to address that this is not a
guy that would probably sit on my couch
and really want to talk he's somebody
that i would have to point out again and
again so i notice you're making light of
this but what are you really thinking
and i'm sure i would get back some smart
alec answer where after some time we'd
have this dance of me trying to figure
out how do i actually get to hear what
is going on underneath of this exterior
some people i know really hate new york
city and they walk through the city
saying you know what i get through it
because i imagine it is a movie scene
and people are going to roll the
buildings away and everything's just
fake that is actually a good coping
mechanism that's called dissociation or
even depersonalization where you step
outside of what's going on in your life
there are times when people who've dealt
with a lot of sexual abuse dissociate in
the moment even just to not be present
not to have to deal with it breaking the
fourth wall might be a reflection of
that how deadpool does dissociate or
depersonalize what's going on in his
life right now so he doesn't have to
deal with it he can break the fourth
wall joke around he has this awareness
so it's a way to get through all the
suffering that he's actually going
through i don't necessarily think
deadpool meets criteria for
post-traumatic stress disorder there's
another diagnosis called other trauma or
stress-related disorder meaning that
there's been significant trauma it's
affected someone's life in a way that
continues how they interact with people
how they function and that's certainly
something that we see here green goblin
so many good things all happening for
you
all for you
norman
what do you want
to say what you want
to do what you can't
to remove
those in your way
norman osborne seems to have the onset
of a psychotic disorder he's a bit old
for that to happen just naturally there
are usually ages at which you see this
present in
males
between mid teens to early 20s
and for
women you might see
later teens to later in the 20s that's a
time of onset for schizophrenia
schizophrenia is a psychotic disorder
meaning there's a break from reality in
which someone starts to have
hallucinations they might hear things or
see things that aren't really there
might have disorganized thinking there
might be paranoia difficulty with
actually interacting with other people
really disordered thoughts in this case
norman does hear what seemed like
hallucinations he hears this voice
wondering where it comes from people who
have psychosis have said you know it
feels like it's in my head but i don't
want it there it's it's kind of being
put there but
it's really hard to tell the difference
between what's really in their head
what's really external and we see that
in norman here he's kind of playing this
out he's almost having a conversation in
fact he is having a conversation with
his voice
that can happen in psychotic disorders
it doesn't just have to be schizophrenia
in this scene you see a reflection of
norman so you see him talking as himself
as norman and then you look in the
mirror and you see green goblin or you
hear the green goblin and you kind of
see a little bit of a different
hairstyle to norman as well when that
happens that can be a reflection
literally and truly and figuratively
also
of different parts of this
brain he has he's got
this one that is realistic sound mind
that's norman and then he has this one
psychotic voice that comes in
and so that's another reflection of
what's going on in him not a reflection
of him per se the voice in psychosis
doesn't necessarily have to reflect that
individual in fact that's often why it's
so awful it doesn't reflect who they are
coward
we have a new world to conquer
you make me sick with me alone
please hiding in the shadows
there are different types of
auditory hallucinations some are called
persecutory hallucinations and what that
means is that the voice is saying really
negative things to the individual really
criticizing them really making them feel
awful about themselves here we see the
example of a persecutory delusion or
persecutory hallucination the voice he's
hearing is calling him a coward you can
see he's he's just so helpless here to
that voice and desperately wanting to
get rid of it the smashing of the mask
is a desperation of wanting this to stop
and we do see that in real life we do
see individuals who just want those
voices to stop sometimes they have their
hands on their heads saying
stop stop you can actually see that in
real life and this is a reflection of
his desire to make it to stop the
interesting thing is he gets this onset
of psychosis from the goblin serum
that's been researched here in real life
there's an equivalent not the goblin
serum but to actually taking something
that makes you have psychotic
episodes
there are reports of people using
methamphetamine and for some people they
develop an ongoing psychosis it doesn't
just happen during the time when they're
using in those
first few times but actually can even go
on for reports of 15 years or longer so
there is some reality to having
something cause you to have psychosis
and when i see somebody of this age
suddenly having that onset that's what i
would ask right away is there any
substance use what's been going on there
iron man
how did you get out of the world
wait a minute tony
[Music]
check the heart check to check that is
the brain
no sign of cardiac anomaly or unusual
brain activity okay so it's poison
my diagnosis is that you've experienced
a severe anxiety attack
me here tony stark is having panic
attack a panic attack is a sudden onset
of this feeling like things are out of
control
often times people will go to the
hospital thinking they're having a heart
attack because their heart might be
beating faster they might have physical
sensations and physical tightness clammy
hands these are similar to
the symptoms of the heart attack he just
feels like he is getting more worked up
something's wrong he's hyperventilating
iron man has been through a lot of
trauma he's lost
people he's actually seen things not
succeed all of that's playing a role on
his mind it's on his mind so it's quite
possible that there is a trigger here
it's this building is building this
building and then the little child says
to him as he's starting already to
develop some panic attack symptoms and
the kid says how'd you get out of the
wormhole well that wormhole is the
trauma and it seems like at that moment
that's when he just gets out he's like i
gotta get out of here. so it's building
and then it stops panic attacks can be
really quick they can sometimes last for
10 minutes maybe a little bit longer
anxiety can go on and on and on and on
in his case because of all this trauma
and all the things that recently
happened to him at this point in the
movie series he does have a lot on his
shoulders he's he's really got a lot
he's processing oftentimes people who
have a lot of trauma will try not to
think about it and one way they try not
to think about it is by using alcohol
using substances they're not saying hey
let me use substances to stop thinking
about my trauma but some people do have
an awareness enough to say this makes me
not think about anything i don't want to
have to deal with anything so i'm just
going to go use this or drink that in
tony's case he does have alcoholism
and alcoholism is quite often linked to
traumatic experiences but sometimes it's
not some people are genetically
predisposed to develop alcoholism it's
not everybody having alcohol suddenly
becomes an alcoholic there can be a
genetic predisposition to that and there
are story lines demon in a bottle in the
iron man lore
where it shows how much this has a grip
on him hulk
what's really compelling about this is
the look he gives it's such a look of
shame
when he changes from human form into
this green mass anger and shame are two
of the most difficult emotions that i
see people dealing with
sometimes they go together people have
anger at individuals or at situations in
their lives and often they don't know
what to do with it sometimes people are
so ashamed of having anger towards
others
that they don't want to talk about it
shame is different than guilt guilt is a
feeling of i've done something wrong i
feel bad about what i've done shame is a
feeling that you're entirely bad you're
a whole person there's nothing good
about you and in the moments when
bruce is becoming the hulk i think he
feels that is there anything good about
him he can't control this he's getting
to a place where he knows he can't
control who he is and there might be
shame over what he might do talking to
bruce moore about these episodes i
learned that he has repeated episodes of
outbursts that they're not premeditated
or thought of beforehand
that there might be
physical aggression and in fact there is
physical aggression and destruction i
would start to think is there an
intermittent explosive disorder that's
the diagnosis for anger outbursts like
this
we don't know what causes that
intermittent explosive disorder does fit
and he's really ashamed of that looking
at a different version of the hulk david
banner maybe in the multiverse somewhere
else this can present a little bit
differently but there's other themes
here it's okay
it's okay
that
and understand we can can you speak
okay are you hurt
sometimes people dealing with anger
really do feel like it's out of control
they don't know how to manage it so you
can talk with them about well what
happens when you get angry what do you
get out of doing that what are you
thinking what are you feeling so you can
go through it with them
and just really understand more when i
see bruce banner the second time he's
actually changed his name to david
banner and he looks a little bit
different he's talking to me this time
about how he went through a horrible
episode where he was in a car he was in
an accident and his wife was trapped in
the car and he couldn't get her out she
died and so he became more and more
interested in learning about how do
people suddenly harness strength to be
able to save a loved one in time of a
crisis like that
so some of his presentation i'm starting
to learn
maybe there's shame over not being able
to save his wife this is incredibly
traumatic so he's dealing with
that on his mind all the time i couldn't
save my wife couldn't save my wife
that's propelled him to study oh was
there some positioning of the sun such
that the gamma radiation
out in the environment actually help
someone harness strength and that's what
leads to these experiments
and that's what leads him to transform
into the incredible hulk
an interesting approach from a
psychological perspective is that this
anger that fuels the hulk and that he's
so ashamed of ends up being a superpower
it ends up helping him do good work in
therapy sometimes i'm really trying to
help people see that anger doesn't have
to be a bad thing they don't have to be
scared of it something good or
productive can come out of it so there
is that theme being played out in these
shows and these movies
moon
all right
listen to me
look at me
look at me not real this is real i'm
real no you're not really yes
stephen you got to give me control it's
the only way stephen is communicating
with mark
the idea is that this is a dissociative
identity disorder meaning that an
individual often linked to trauma
has developed some way of coping with
that trauma there's another personality
in this case
mark is one personality stephen is the
other and they're very different mark is
considered to be the tougher person and
he's trying to convince steven let me
take over let me take over moon knight
needs mark and needs that presence in
order to take over and that's what we
see here could moon knight be another
altar that's possible but there's also
the whole supernatural element of this
egyptian god inhabiting mark what's not
quite realistic here is that an altar
doesn't necessarily
have a communication with the other
alter there's not a conversation like
this and certainly not back and forth
the important part here is to realize
there are levels of trauma for the
individual that has a dissociative
identity disorder in mark's case he has
a military background and there's
certainly trauma involved in his
background stephen is a meeker
individual often the idea behind an
altar is that an altar protects the host
now whether stephen is the host whether
steve is the altar
we learn those things during the story
but is it that stephen needs protection
does mark need to protect stephen from
this sometimes when people shift from
one altar to another there is amnesia
they don't remember things and often we
think that's because they go from one
personality state to another and that
explains the amnesia what you also
notice is mark has an american accent
and stephen has a british accent alters
can have different personality traits
than the host it's not uncommon to see
an altar have a limp or some other
physical nuance that the host doesn't
have there can even be
reported cases of blood sugar changes
with one alter versus another so that's
something that does fall in line with
the dissociative identity
disorder again here the main issue is
that he's coping with some kind of
trauma
and that's where this dissociation comes
from decision of identity disorder
involves multiple alters and it's
unclear how someone develops that
particular alter with that idea in mind
that the altar is doing something to
protect the host it could be that one
alter offers something like a strength
one alter offers something like
intelligence there might be different
nuances to each alter to provide some
kind of protection or something for the
host maybe that's an amalgamation of
things that that person has seen or
taken in maybe they have seen other
people have a certain strength or a
certain way of being and they
incorporate that but it's not
necessarily conscious it's something
that could be internalized and then it
comes out in this way not everybody who
has trauma develops dissociative
identity disorder sometimes the trauma's
been so much so hard for somebody to
deal with that this is a way of coping
with that some providers have said the
goal is to integrate the personalities
the goal of psychotherapy is really to
help the individual so helping them heal
from whatever trauma it is giving them a
space to talk about it figuring out
what's really going on
that might result in the consolidation
of alters and meaning that
there isn't a multiple or diverse
group of personalities anymore but just
individuals
thanos
titan was like most planets
too many mouths not enough to go around
and when we faced extinction i offered a
solution
genocide
but random is passionate fair to rich
and poor alike
they called me a madman i don't find him
to be classically psychopathic and that
he doesn't care about anybody because
he's actually trying to save the world
sometimes i would wonder is there a
delusion that he's under is is there a
delusion that
he's actually going to save the world by
killing half of the population
but in reality maybe the world is
overpopulated you see in the movie
people supportive of thanos saying yeah
he's right
are they extremists is he being extreme
possibly so he's a really complicated
character
pretty isn't it
perfectly balanced this whole thing
should be
too much to one side
or the
other
sometimes you can have balance
focus in ocd or obsessive compulsive
disorder you can be really obsessed with
things being even
so sometimes i will see children who
feel like they've moved their left leg
twice and then they feel compelled to
move their right leg twice
or if they've touched the doorknob three
times on the left side they will touch
it three times on the right side this is
a balancing
type of ocd i don't see that with thanos
i don't see an obsession here with
balance i see him being very fixated on
wanting to save the world by deleting
half of it maybe it's a cognitive
dissonance in that
he feels like okay
i am killing people that's really bad
i should actually just refer to them as
the population that needs to go but
there's no cognitive dissonance here
because he doesn't feel a pull he
doesn't feel like it's wrong he's just
doing what he's convinced is right
loki the grand master has a great many
ships i may even have stolen the access
codes to his security system and
suddenly you're overcome with an urge to
do the right thing heavens no
i run out of favor with the grand master
and in exchange for codes and access to
a ship i'm asking for safe passage
through the anus
if i ever feel like someone's not being
truthful to me or not being forthcoming
i'm often thinking what's the reason
sometimes people do get joy out of
manipulating other people or sometimes
people have just a goal in mind they
want to accomplish so they are going to
manipulate people to do that and often
that's what loki was doing he's trying
to manipulate thor into this or that to
get what he wanted what i think would be
most interesting about loki would be to
have had family therapy with loki and
thor and odin and frigga to talk with
that family together would have been
really interesting thor and loki grow up
with the parents and odin much prefers
thor whereas friega recognizes that loki
might have this feeling that he can't
accomplish anything and she becomes
closer to him this is very often the
case in families where a parent has a
child even though they say oh there's no
favorites i love all my kids they have
favorites or they have relationships
with their kids that they enjoy more
than others most parents don't go out to
do a bad job of parenting but they
overlook something they overlook that
they're not developing the relationship
with the child that the child needs it
would be great to hear from odin what
does he feel about loki why is he drawn
to thor and we know some of this but i'd
like to hear it directly from the
father's mouth it would be interesting
too to have the brothers talk about the
sibling rivalry kids pick up on things
they're intuitive even when those things
aren't said by parents they still pick
up on it loki's no fool he's actually
really smart and he knows that the
father prefers thor the fathers even sat
thor and loki down and said
he values peace
but one of you is going to take the
throne
clearly they recognize one of them is
going to take the throne well who's it
going to be
so loki and thor from early ages have
this rivalry
and this disagreement right away his
lying his pathological lying his
manipulation of other people thinking i
just did a
quick fyi i was just talking to him just
a couple minutes ago and he was totally
ready to kill any of us he did try to
kill me yes me too
many occasions i do wonder is there some
antisocial personality disorder traits
there anti-social personality disorder
means you have no regard for laws you're
willing to break the rules you do what
you need to get what you want that's
what he does it doesn't necessarily mean
if you have anti-social personality
disorder you're a psychopath which is
someone who really doesn't care about
other people they're callous
and they just do whatever they want in
fact we see loki change over time he
becomes more compassionate he's exposed
at one point to all of these experiences
to his behaviors both current past and
future and he realizes over time that he
can be a good person and you see this
evolution of him over time so that shows
a really interesting aspect of this
character that he develops and changes
over time he's not necessarily
antisocial that can also be the case
somebody who is showing antisocial
traits when they're younger they call
that conduct disorder when kids are
breaking rules and teenagers are
breaking the law and not seeming to have
regard for it that can change not
everybody with conic disorder develops
antisocial personality disorder and
becomes a career criminal so this can
change over time and clearly he does
have a change of heart over time thanks
so much for watching these clips with me
i hope you learned something and i'll
see you at our next session